what top items for you girls give you
the
E A guy who talk a
lot talks a lot about anything specific
or just talks too much like just talks
too much about their feelings like I
don't want to know about
it okay so you don't want a guy crying
on your shoulder like a little uh I
think um what happen is when someone
certain traits comes with personality
like for example when woman go I want to
get have a guy who likes you know who
can talk to me like you wouldn't get a
guy who is successful who wants to talk
to you about your feelings like it just
doesn't exist that's why you need a
girlfriend right so me if I know for a
fact if a guy have too much time to talk
it's a red flag like um they are not
they have too much time in their hands
like they should be doing something with
their life talking about feelings like
they should be able to manage that
emotion they should be doing all that
like it's so I don't like guys like to
talk okay anything else from other
girls like I don't know for me like I
guess a personal like I like I guess two
and one would be uh someone that isn't
that has like no motivation right that
has no motivation to in their career
just in life in general like I just
because yeah I would like someone that
would be motivated that could support a
potential family right and be able to to
give in that way but also it for me it's
like guys that only will talk about
themselves like I've gone out with them
and like you try and like add to the
conversation they'll never like
elaborate on what you're talking about
because like might what you're talking
about might not completely interest me
but it's about you so I'm interested to
learn about you right like I've listened
to men talk about like working out and I
don't go to the gym but I'll listen and
I'll engage in it because it's it's a
you know something that's interesting to
them so when you just have someone
that's just very one-sided in
communication that's a bit of a turnoff
for me the level of ambition that you're
looking for like what like how much
money does it have to make like what
sort of income would you need for you
see but it's I don't know I don't have a
number right it's just you just have to
have something that's reliable right
like something I like because I've gone
out with someone it was like a long time
ago and he hopped like he was a hopper
and he jumped from job to job and then
every time he would he would apply for
jobs that he wasn't qualified for but
then would talk as though he had done
this job for 15 years and he'd never
like a masonry he had never laid brick
in his life right it was just like I
just yeah like I guess I want stability
right so someone that has a job that's
stable yeah you've got a good stable job
I mean you'll always a job because the
healthare system is always going to need
you there you've got yourself unionized
probably I would imagine in too right um
nurses make over 100,000 there yeah so
yeah I I do because well yeah I work a
lot overtime so yes yeah I do so I mean
if you had a stable guy that works I
don't know at the counter at Shoppers
Drug Mart uh you know dispensing the
Pharmaceuticals makes I don't know
whatever he makes 60 70 grand or
something like that like is that
sufficient like is that a stable job is
that it's stable like you know what I
mean money yeah like I'm not looking at
someone for like the dollar sign right
cuz like I was I was you know raised
very moderate like you know what I mean
I guess like you say like like lower
midlevel income and so I I don't have
value on things right like I just I just
don't have the value on that and so if
someone is able to provide me like you
know emot you know what I mean just like
the security emotionally like just to
have a like to have someone in my life
that way that that's more important to
me do you find that most of the guys
that you that you go out with don't meet
that criteria of being stable and
ambitious no the ones recent like the
ones that I have gone out with have all
been stable okay yeah it's just that
you've expressed interest they haven't
chosen you back sort of thing there's
just no real connection or it's just
sexual for them or something like that
well the last like long-term
relationship I was in was very it was
like I call it toxic because it was like
a light switch it was on and off for
like two and a half years right so it
was a very toxic relationship and he was
stable but it was just a very very toxic
relationship and yeah so it just didn't
it just ended up not working because of
like the negative hit history that kept
getting brought into it every time we
would like try again what was the um
what was the light switch turning on and
off oh that's what I called it because
it was like what was it I our
relationship like we were on again off
again on again off again so I called it
like a light switch okay so you're like
breaking up and getting back together
yeah it was yeah it was just it was very
unhealthy but like at the end of the day
no one forced me to go back to him I
chose it every time right so I can't
blame anyone but myself for that so what
were the breakups
over it was just a lot of um messiness
with his
ex and he didn't have the boundaries set
there and so there was just lots of
infiltration exwife or I guess like
ex-girlfriend they he had children with
her yeah it was just like an ex okay so
there was there it it was a very toxic
relationship there and he didn't have
the boundar set for our relationship so
it just kind of always overflowed into
ours and caused most of the
issues I want to come back to you and
hear from you a little bit on your
experience dating a guy with kids um man
we're talking about the E what's your
what's your top EG
items um I don't know I feel
like I don't know maybe not having a car
because I feel
like I don't know living in La you kind
of need a car and expecting me to like
come to you and pick you up and come to
you and pick you up or like send you a
uber how many times I've been told like
send me a uber is
ridiculous men have asked you to send
them in Uber to pick them up I will like
immediately stop talking to you if ask
me for money like unless we're like
committed and we've been going strong
and you're like struggling I'm I'm going
to help you I'm going to be there but if
we're just barely getting to know each
other like in like the first like month
or something then
I'm no I'm pin the block button um m m
we're at the point where dudes are
asking women to send them in Uber I mean
it's kind of common for like only fans
girls if you're like talking to someone
that they're very common to ask for
money like pretty they ask you for money
yeah wow so you end up being like a
sugar mama they try they try me okay
interesting there was something else you
about to say
um
uh I don't know gotta be more than that
I mean no car is a huge one I don't
think we've heard that yet on this show
I think that would be like everybody
would say that but I mean it's funny
that's you have specific experience in
that yeah it's kind of different oh um
if like you get mad at me for like
working rather than like going out all
the time like I need somebody who is
probably just as a home body as I am um
because I kind of went through like my
clubbing phase with my friends and
everything so like hopefully somebody
like who's not in their Club phase
anymore and like we can go out once in a
while with our friends but like if
you're going out all the time probably
not I really hope you guys enjoy that
clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out